from the national university of
singapore talking about efficient
distant estimation and causal inference
for discrete models thank you okay thank
you and thank you for being here early
in the morning and thank you to the
organizers for this great workshop
so i'm going to talk about efficient
algorithms for estimating distance
between vision networks and
for learning
post-interventional distributions in
causal models this is joint work with a
bunch of people who have mentioned
during the talk
so let me just kind of do a bit of setup
so suppose you're a cancer researcher
right and you are
measuring uh biomarkers for uh
for various
various kind of biomarkers so you have
hormone levels gene expression levels
presence or absence of antibodies other
growth factors and markers indicating
presence of tumors
and you have many of these markers okay
so you can measure
many of them i mean and throughout the
talk will denote the number of variables
or the dimension of the data
and
you observe these samples for
several individuals right and the goal
after you obtain this data is to answer
statistical or or causal queries so
statistical queries would be like you
would be asking about the joint
distribution on some subset of variables
causal queries would ask i mean what
would happen if you administer a
treatment that affects a few of these
variables and you ask about the effect
on on some other way right
and the way we typically model this is
that we think of these as n random
variables and these variables are of
course
i mean the whole point is that these are
not independent uh they are
products of some grand physical process
and the idea of causal inference is to
learn
properties about this underlying
generative process okay
so how do we model this process which is
generating these variables so we kind of
go back to laplace in the 1800s who
who thought i mean who kind of
envisioned a deterministic evolution of
the universe so the universe kind of is
a is an effect of its past and
determines its future so this is kind of
the way that will model the generation
of
variables so you have
just this one yeah so
each variable is a deterministic
function of its parent set of variables
this is a subset of the variables and
some other set of variables that are
unmeasured that you don't know so the
stochasticity in the evolution comes
from the fact that these uis are unknown
latent variables that are not measured
but we'll think of these functions as
being deterministic okay and the way
often that will depict this causal model
is by a causal diagram where you have
variables as nodes you have edges from
parents to children and if there's no
dashed arc between two variables like
between x1 and x2 and x2 and x4 the
the corresponding uis the randomness
we'll think of as independent but if
there is an arc then
the randomness is dependent so without
loss of generality we can take u2 to be
equal to u3 and this is what's known as
confounding so x2 and x3 are confirmed
right
um and
right so throughout we'll assume that
this causal diagram is acycling ac click
so which means that the uh that the uh
that there's a linear ordering in which
the variables are being generated one
after the other um and without if
there's no confounding so if there is no
dash starts then basically this just
corresponds to a standard bayesian
network where you have each node there's
a conditional distribution of the node
given its parents and then that
completely determines the whole system
and also i mean this way of writing it
explicitly specifies the effects of what
it would mean to administer a treatment
okay so maybe let me just give a very
simple example just to make sure that we
are all on the same page so if you have
two variables x1 and x2 right and you
have a
latent variable u which is common
between x1 and x2 and the functional
equation is x1 equal to u and x2 is
equal to u
xor x1
okay and u
is just uniform on 0 and 1 okay so then
the observational distribution so x2
is
0 with probability 1
right because
x1 is equal to
u
but
but x2 do x1 equal to 0. so what do x1
equal to 0 is exactly this intervention
where you go in and you specifically set
1 to be equal to a particular value so
if i set x 1 equal to 0 so this means
that on the right hand side i change
this x 1 to 0 so x 2 do x 1 equal to 0
is basically distributed again uniformly
in 0 1 because x 1 x 2 becomes
equal to u okay so this is the notion of
intervention so it's a completely i mean
right so
so if you write it this way the i mean
it explicitly specifies what an
intervention means
uh
so we'll try to make minimal assumptions
so we'll have uh so the n the number of
nodes or the dimension of the data we'll
think of as asymptotically growing
and for statistical computational
reasons i mean we'll i mean the goal of
this
the work that i'll describe will be to
understand the the i mean to recover the
causal model or to recover the some
parameters of the puzzle model
and so we'll need to assume some sort of
sparsity on the model okay so typically
we will assume that the
the in degree of each node is bounded
which means that the each node can be
written
i mean the width of this functional
equation description
this is bounded and also we'll assume
that the
the dashed edges have bounded span so
for example you cannot have some god
hidden variable which confounds
everything else because this would mean
that you can have an arbitrary
distribution on on the end variables and
this is not tractable
and finally we'll work with discrete
variables over a finite alphabet but
this assumption can be relaxed right but
we will throughout assume just um
discrete variables or even if you like
just boolean variables okay
okay and finally i mean throughout the
talk i'll be um
i'll be talking about approximation
of probability distributions and to
define approximation i need some notion
of distance between probability
distributions and we'll work with two
notions the total variation or the
statistical distance and kl divergence i
think i'm missing a factor of half here
but it doesn't really matter so this is
so the total variation distance uh you
can define it as the l1 norm between the
probability mass functions and the kl
divergence has an expectation over p of
this log ratio okay
and i mean one important thing to know
notice at least for the first part of
this talk is that if i if p and q denote
distributions over the n n-dimensional
space computing this tv or kl is not a
trivial job right i mean this is like a
sum over an exponential number of uh xs
so you cannot do it
explicitly using this formula
all right um and
so
so tv will be kind of our gold standard
for distance uh
in the stock because if i can say that
the total variation distance between two
distributions is small this also implies
for example the distribution of
marginals is also small
i mean if pq are closed then
their marginals are also closed in total
variation distance um i mean any event
that happens under p
also happens with approximately the same
probability under q so so this will be
the notion that we'll usually work with
all right so let's uh begin so in the
first part of this talk i'll be talking
about algorithms for distance estimation
so just to motivate this right i mean so
i told you about the functional causal
model or bayesian networks if we don't
have confounding
but i mean this is not a unique
description right i mean so you can have
different
bayesian networks which yield the same
observable distribution so this is
the eq markov equivalence class
partitioning of all dags on three
variables so basically all the so if you
have a distribution that can be
expressed uh
as a causal model or a bayes net on this
bag then it can also be expressed in
this diagram this time right so there
are different alternative descriptions
of
distributions in this language and
there's even more ambiguity if we allow
the distributions to be approximately
equal not exactly equal and so the
question is can we test such approximate
equivalence efficient right
and let me just formulate it in this
very crisp way so i'm so just to kind of
hone in on the computational nature of
the problem we look at this question so
you have two distributions p and q
you have the explicit description of
them as base nets okay and the question
is to compute the total variation
distance between these two distributions
okay
now um i mean of course in reality i
mean you may be kind of estimating these
from
samples uh but but just to understand
the computational nature of the problem
let's assume that you have a complete
description yeah so here i mean if
you're given the descriptions of the
networks you can forward sample from
them
so why can't you just estimate the l1 so
by directly sampling from p and then
looking at i mean do you get an unbiased
estimator that way or are you worried
about the
variance uh i mean it's it's not an
expectation right i mean it's a sum of
uh
okay so this is that's one of the things
that we'll discuss i mean like having
unbiased estimators
yeah uh but just saying like if you are
one who computed exactly um
so this is just a purely computational
problem and our first result is that
even for product distributions where the
graph is completely empty uh computing
it exactly is a sharply hard problem so
prior to this work i mean the only
results about
statistical distance was a older world
by uh sahai and vadhan where they showed
that if p and q are
generated by
samplable distribution so that there are
outputs of circuits then um this is a
hard problem but this kind of
strengthens it to i mean even if you
have two product distributions then uh
the total variation distance is hard
computing the total variation this sense
is a hard problem so let me just give
you a brief idea of the proof of this
because i mean it indicates something
important
so the way we prove this is that we
first look at this problem uh pmf equals
which is
the question i mean if you have a
product distribution p and some
particular value v you ask for how many
x's does p of x is equal to b okay
uh and it's not hard to see that this
basically
is a generalization of the subset of the
counting version of subset sum problem
so subset sum is asking if you have a
bunch of numbers for how many sets is a
subset of those numbers equal to for how
many subsets is the sum in that subset
equal to some particular target
um
so so asking if p of x is equal to v uh
you can so if s denotes the set of so
here um let me just assume right so this
is uh
these are distributions from 0 1 to the
n so if s is the set of indices where x
i is equal to 1 then p of x is equal to
v can be written in this way which you
can easily massage into a subset some
kind of um
yeah so you're looking for subsets s
where uh the sum of these quantities is
equal to this so this basically is a
direct reduction of subset sum to pmf
equals
and uh so the key part of the
reduction is the other is i mean showing
the hardness of this pmf equals problem
uh well no sorry so showing that uh pmf
equals reduces to tv computation
and um so what we can show is that so
you can so given a distribution
uh
so you're given a p and q right so
sorry you're given uh an instance of pmf
equals so you can come up with uh
distributions p prime q prime p double
prime and q double prime which are on a
larger number of variables on n plus two
variables instead of n variables so that
the
uh the
the number of x's for p of x is equal to
v can be expressed as a difference
between two total variation distance
computations
okay
and uh right so if you have efficient
algorithms for total variation distances
and basically it also implies efficient
algorithm for this pmf equals problem
which is a hard problem okay um
so yeah one thing is that because we do
that this is this kind of a touring
reduction where you have a difference
and it doesn't rule out
a relative approximation i mean it could
be that you have um
you could have like very good
approximation of the tv distance but the
difference could be a very bad
approximation of the
of the left hand side right so it
doesn't rule out approximation but at
least it shows that uh that
that exact computation is
right
okay
um yeah
do you know if the problem is
yeah it isn't yes it's a sharpie
completely
okay um okay but in fact even
approximation is hard if you just allow
degree two okay so deciding whether tv
of pq equals zero or not uh is np hard
if the degree is allowed to be two and
this is actually a very simple reduction
uh i can just quickly show it and so
this basically also implies that
relative approximation so multiplicative
approximation of pv distance is going to
be hard because if you have a
multiplicative approximation you can
distinguish between whether the tv
distance is zero or or uh not zero
and this is just a very simple reduction
from circuit sat so if you have a
um
a circuit a boolean circuit
um and you're trying to decide whether
it's satisfiable or not so you can
reduce it to
reduce it to the tv computation between
these two bayesian networks okay so what
we do is just we
we endow the inputs with the uniform
distribution
and the
the the gates in the middle they are
deterministic functions i mean the way
they usually are
and uh so we just stand an extra node so
in one case it's the uniform
distribution which is just independent
of everything else the other case it's
an or between the output gate and a
uniform distribution okay so if for
example this this instance was not
satisfiable so x9 was always false
then
this x 10 i mean is going to be just
uniform so these two distributions are
going to be identical right
and it's easy to see that if it is
satisfiable then the distance will be
non-zero so so tv of pq is non-zero if
and only if the circuit sat instance is
satisfiable so this
tells you that
that there is a
that time yeah so deciding 0 versus
non-zero is
uh is a hard problem so so just one
remark i mean it's not possible that i
mean there's this tv zero versus
non-zero of course for product
distributions it's actually an easy
problem right i mean if you have a
product distribution
you just have to check whether the
parameters are equal or not that's the
only way that two product distributions
can be identical but once you get to a
degree which is at least two then you
have at least np hardness so you don't
know the true hardness of the
approximation problem actually um
and
um yeah but then
i think building on ankur's idea you can
so additive approximation is possible
okay and you can do it efficiently
and here's the idea i mean which i mean
you can build an estimator uh which
you can evaluate empirically so what you
do is you look at this l1 norm and you
can write it in this way so you can take
out p of x
and you can write this sum in this way
okay
and the nice thing is that this
estimate is kind of bounded is between
zero and one so you can just easily draw
samples from p
and if you have the parameters of these
two distributions p and q you can
exactly evaluate uh p of x and q of x
right so you can evaluate this for
excess that you sample from p right and
by a standard turn off bound you can
estimate the tv up to plus or minus
epsilon okay and this works not only if
you have exact uh uh
description of p and q uh if you so if
you learn p and q from samples uh which
i'll describe in the next part of the
talk so if you learn p and q up to some
total variation distance error okay and
you plug in so instead of using the
exact values of q and p here you use q
hat and p hat which you learn from
samples then also you can show that this
is a plus minus epsilon approximation
okay
um
and this general idea is kind of okay by
the way i mean so so the way this
testing algorithm works is by
um is by actually learning the
parameters first like i said and then
you use that q hat and p hat for
uh for evaluating this estimate it's
still an open question if you can do
plus minus uh distance approximation
without actually resorting to learning
okay
um
yeah so
is an additive approximation i see
yeah
this
what about multiplicative approximately
yeah so i'll talk about that so
multiplicative we saw that even if the
degree becomes at least two it becomes a
hard problem
uh but we can still say something about
when the degree is less than two
um
right uh yeah and then this strategy
kind of is actually quite general right
i mean like this doesn't actually rely
on anything about bayes net so it's an
interesting question even if you give me
two uh high dimensional gaussians and
ask me i mean you give me the parameters
of the gaussian and you ask me what is
the total variation distance so there's
no kind of explicit formula uh for com
for the total variation distance between
two uh gaussians but you can use this
strategy to get a good additive
approximation because again if you have
the parameters you can uh
of the gaussian you can evaluate the
probability density function right and
similarly for paramagnetic icing models
you can compute you can approximate the
partition function and you can get a
approximation of these q n
okay yeah so the
question you are asked is about the
this
relative approximation i find this a
fascinating question
so what we showed is that i mean a bit
surprisingly polynomial time
approximation algorithm is possible in
some cases when you have uh product
distributions
for example let me just sketch what
happens when q is uniform right so
suppose you're trying to test
you're trying to approximate the
distance from arbitrary product
distribution
uh and uniform
so
so essentially you can reduce this to
approximate knapsack counting okay so
what happens is that you
take
the pis
right so the pi's are the parameters of
the product distribution so the total
variation distance you can write it in
this way
and you can just kind of
separate this sum into uh
i mean you can ask for how many sets
this guy will contribute something in
some range okay
and that basically reduces to
approximate knives accounting so
counting how many sets where this
quantity falls in some range
is essentially approximate maps
accounting and you can use um now
classical algorithm due to dire to do
this task okay and
yeah and using an idea due to raghu and
co-authors we can so where i mean they
use ideas for um
read one's branching program and like
for
sampling from read one's branching
program so we can extend this to more
general classes of product distribution
okay
okay so any questions about this part
we still don't have a complete
understanding of for what product
distributions the
the
you have hardness versus where you have
a polynomial time approximation scheme
okay so let me then go to the second
part of the talk which is about
distribution learning so here
the question is that you're given well
okay so let me first say in general what
the problem is right so you're given um
so you will assume that the causal
diagram is known okay this is part of
the domain knowledge the causal diagram
is known
and you get samples from
uh the
uh the the i mean the observational
distribution okay
and the goal i mean the the final goal
that we'll look at is being able to uh
generate a description of the
interventional distribution so what
happens when i uh
do an intervention on a subset of
variables i'd like to get a description
of that interventional distribution
um so let me let's just start very slow
and ask what happens just with the
observational distribution so i get
observations and i'm trying to learn the
observational distribution uh given that
that okay this is just fixed structure
learning where the structure is known
and you're just trying to learn the
parameters of the of the bayesian
network all right and yeah so this is
the first case where you have no
confounding right so here
i mean this is a
well studied classic question so so it's
clear what you do
if you have thought about these things
right i mean so you take each variable
and you try to learn the the the
neighborhood i mean so for each
variable you just learn the distribution
um conditioned on experience taking on
some values
so so define pi sigma to be the
distribution of x i when the parents of
x i have value sigma
and um and our strategy is to just uh
estimate these distributions p i sigma
squared okay so i i just want to pause
for a moment to contrast to the talk
yesterday for example by raghu where i
mean he was trying to learn the graph
itself right so here
the graph is known so the question is to
learn a distribution okay
guarantee that we want is that the
distribution should be close in tv
distance to the
uh actual observational distribution to
the true distribution
um
and
we would like to understand as a
function of the
the error in approximation how many
samples you need okay
um
okay
so right so we just want to estimate
these local
distributions these conditional
probability distributions at each node
and there's a very nice fact about
bayesian networks that you can decompose
the kl divergence between
two
bayesian networks on the same graph so
if p and q are
bayesian networks on the same graph then
you can write the scale divergence as
the sum over the variables of the
expectation over the distribution to its
parents of so the sigma is an assignment
to the parents of x i of the kl
divergence between pi sigma and qi sigma
okay
so all that you need to do is to be able
to
take enough samples to make sure that
you estimate the scale divergence
for each of the i and sigma
to small error right
i mean it's not really necessary to
estimate each of them because if some
sigma happens with some very small
probability then you can essentially i
mean unless your kl kind of blows up
you can
we can discard those sigmas which have
extremely small probability and we only
look at the sigmas which have
sufficiently large probability okay
but it is an issue that we don't want kl
to become infinity which it can right so
we just have to ensure that this stays
bounded and then we need to uh
estimate the this pi sigma for those
sigmas where
the probability of the parents having
sigma takes on some significant problem
okay so so first this is general
question so if you have two yeah yeah
can you assume that if you have the same
structure right assuming that the graph
is known okay for both of them yeah yeah
so here the graph is known and you're
just trying to learn the description of
the distribution but i think this
decomposition is true independent of the
problem it also works if you just
decompose pq in terms of unconditionals
uh
yeah i think um i mean so if the parents
are different
i think you need i think so but we can
talk about it okay sure yeah i think one
of them
yeah i mean there are some extra terms
otherwise and there are some additive
terms i think if
one of them is not um
but we're going to talk about it yeah
okay uh
right so so just like a very simple
question so how do you ensure
um that pi sigma and qi sigma are closed
so these are just distributions so let's
say that all the variables are from 1
through k so these are just
distributions on 1 through k right so i
just want to learn a distribution on 1
through k so that the kl divergence is
small
so this is a basic question and actually
i mean as far as i know the optimal
answer is still not known um so if so
one thing that you can do is you can use
what's called the add one estimator so
if you get
so if you have a distribution on 1
through k i can define this add one
estimator which is
um
i mean basically the empirical
distribution but you add one to the
count of uh of everything right so if i
so the empirical distribution would have
been ni over n where ni is the number of
times i appears so here i do n i plus 1
over n plus k so i add 1 to the counts
of all the all the
possible domain elements and
right so we showed that
that there is basically i mean you can
that you have this high probability
result so if you take sufficiently many
samples then the kl divergence uh
decreases so if m is the number of
samples then the then with probability
one minus delta the kl divergence uh
decays at this rate
um yeah so we actually don't know how to
remove these long factors
i mean for this basic question that's an
interesting
problem anyway so you can apply this
directly
and um yeah so you can basically
so like i said i mean you have to do
something about those sigma's which
happen with low probability versus those
with high probability but you can take
care of that and you get that you can
take linear in the number of n
and exponential in k which is the the
alphabet size
and the exponent is d plus 1 d is the
maximum degree okay
and then you get this guarantee that the
kl divergence between p and q is at most
epsilon with high probability and this
sample complexity is nearly optimal
um
what about if there's confounding so if
there's confounding then the
then okay so with arbitrary confounding
like i said m you can just have like an
arbitrary distribution on n variables
and you can't do anything so we can use
this notion of c component which was
introduced by uh beijing um so there you
have a
so you define a c component as a
connected component through dash dot so
for example here x z2 z3 and y form one
connector one one c component okay
and uh and essentially for this problem
it's quite easy you can so so you can
think of x z2 z3 and y as just kind of
one block of variables which for which
we don't know
for which there's no bayes net structure
and then you can simply uh
increase the degree
by uh by a factor which depends on the
size of the c component okay so if you
assume that that each c component has
bounded size then you can get a similar
bound for the sample complexity of
learning the
the distribution
okay another interesting question is how
do you learn uh a distribution on a
subset right so even
but you might be able to approximate
things like you know the do distribution
or other kinds of things
yeah so we'll talk about that okay all
right so this is just a description of
the observational distribution on these
environments but really we want to get
to interventional distribution okay um
yeah before i go to that i mean let me
just also
ask another natural question when you
don't want to learn the distribution on
the on the whole set of end variables
but you only want to learn a description
of a distribution on on a subset right
this is again a basic question
um so yeah so what do we really mean by
a description um so there are two ways
that you can think of what it means to
learn a distribution right so one is
you output the learning algorithm
if it it's outputting q it outputs a box
which is a sampler for queue so you
press a button and you get a
variable which is distributed according
to q
um another possibility is that you get
an evaluator which evaluates the
probability mass function so you you
press you input z into the evaluator and
you out and you get as output q of c
okay
um
so these are two different ways that you
can
describe a distribution
so learning a sampler is easy for the
marginal basically you can i mean easy
in the sense that
we have algorithms which are linear time
in the size of the whole network uh
basically you just learn q0 on all the
variables and then you throw away the
variables you don't care about and you
get the variables
on s um learning an evaluator is
actually hard so we can show that um
that it's hard for this complexity class
s z k
um a complete class is the graph
isomorphism problem so it's at least as
hard as that okay
okay so finally let's go to uh yeah the
the interventional question where you
have a
diagram with confounding present
and you get um
you get access to observations and you
would like again a description of a
distribution that approximates the
interventional distribution so again i'm
satisfied with any uh description that
is either as an evaluator or as a sample
right so okay so first of all there's
this basic identifiability issue that
that that for certain kinds of uh
diagrams
even infinitely many samples from the
observational distribution does not
yield enough information about the
interventional right and let's just go
through a quick example just to make
sure that we are all on the same page so
here is the example that i drew on the
board earlier where you have x1 equal to
u1 and x3 equal to x1 xor e1 so in the
observational distribution x2 is 0 with
probability 1 and you can just look at
another distribution where x 2 is really
0 with positive 1 there's no way to
distinguish between the two using
observations but of course the
interventional distributions are
different right
on the other hand there are
diagrams where you can actually find the
interventional distribution this is the
classic front door example
so for any causal model on this diagram
you can you have this formula which
expresses the interventional
distribution in terms of the
observational distribution right
i say any there's a slight catch in this
i mean these conditional
probabilities need to be defined so so
as long as the conditional probabilities
are defined
this gives you a way to to express the
dimensional distribution as a function
of the observational probabilities okay
uh so
okay so the question is um
right and
jin and
julia pearl and schwitzer and pearl they
exactly characterized the the puzzle
diagrams for which interventional
distributions are identifiable and not
identifiably from observations uh so for
simplicity let's just look at the atomic
intervention case where you're
intervening on just one variable so
their characterization was that it's
identifiable if and only if
no child of x is in the same c component
as x so for example in this diagram
there's one child of x z1 it's not in
the same c component as x so the c
component of x is z 2
y and z 3. so z 1 is not there so here
it is actually i mean
so the intervention on x is actually
identifiable from observations okay
okay um right so our result basically uh
strengthens this so to say that
if you have um so if the identifiability
condition of course needs to be
satisfied in order to anything you also
need a positivity assumption i mean just
like i said even there you needed a
positivity assumptions on the
conditional so here i need to assume
that the so s1 is the c component which
contains the variable you are
intervening
and you also look at the parents of the
c component so if those
i mean so any
assignment to these variables occurs
with probability at least alpha so this
so i assume that s1
is a bounded size set i mean so the so i
assume that the c components are bounded
so this is a
statement about a bounded size set
uh and i also assume that this indegree
is at most d and like i said the c
components are bounded by k
then
you can learn the interventional
distribution uh both as st sorry this
should be evaluated evaluator or sampler
using
again
something like n times epsilon to the
minus 2
times this alpha to the minus k
blow up okay where alpha is this
positivity
parameter
and yeah so in a conference next week we
present a paper which generalizes to
larger interventions
let me just quickly tell you
how
why this works basically the way this
works is that you
so okay so like i said i mean there's
you can remove these dashed edges by
blowing up the in degree by a factor
proportional to k so k is the size of
the c component
and then um you can
reduce so okay so the point is that the
interventional distribution
actually turns out to be the marginal
of a bayes net okay
observe so it's the marginal of the
observational distribution on a
different base then okay so you can come
up with another bayes net b okay which
has
um
which is i mean the the diagram of d is
built using this diagram of p so in the
interest of time let me not go into it
and then uh so it suffices to learn the
observational distribution of this new
base net d okay using samples from p
right
and this is where you get this alpha to
the minus k overhead because you need to
generate samples from d using some using
samples from p
and after that you just apply your fixed
structure learning algorithm to learn d
and you marginalize out x okay
um right so uh yeah let me just point
out some interesting questions so
so yeah it would be good to get kind of
non-parametric generalization for
continuous variables for
uh this question also another very
interesting question is robust learning
uh so in the statistics literature in
econometrics people talk about double
robustness or multiple robustness where
you basically have um you have errors in
the regression for
for different
for different parts of this estimate and
the overall error depends only on the
minimum error instead of the maximum
error so can we get something like this
or can we get um i mean yeah
robust learning kind of in the hoover
sense
all right so let me just conclude so i
showed you i mean finite sample pack
style bounds for distribution and causal
learning problems and hopefully i mean
you see the plethora of open problems
that's still about particularly yeah and
those problems that i mentioned at the
end
um
yes one
question that i'm trying to address is i
mean like how to
understand the tools from econometrics
and potential outcome theory um how do
they fit into the picture i have
described i mean can i get pac style
bounds from the semi-parametric
estimators
uh that people use in these fields and
also i mean what i talked about is
counter factual learning is
interventional learning so i think
caroline uhler in a talk a couple of
weeks ago made a good point that i mean
there's this distinction between
interventional learning and
counterfactual learning and in many of
the applications particularly in biology
interventional learning is actually
enough because you want to predict the
result of some treatment but in there
are other situations where i mean you
really want to understand
counterfactuals i mean what would have
happened if something else had happened
and
yeah so it would be also interesting to
put those kinds of questions into this
kind of pack framework
okay so that's it
thanks very much
i have a quick question about
the final result you gave was about
[Music]
can you say can you say what the
connection is between that and an
estimator that achieves that bound so i
wanted to now have an estimator
to achieve
so once you have
once you have a sampler for the
distribution you can use that to
um
to estimate
expectations or
other particular statistical quantities
so you're getting samples from the
interventional distribution and you can
use those samples to estimate some
the quantity of your interest
and so i only need this number of
samples such that the final estimate
is that the
total distribution is epsilon away in
total variation respect so so any
statistic about a marginal and if you
have
just to clarify the left and
[Music]
k but uh
so
right so
so typically often i mean
when one looks at puzzle models you have
continuous variables and you'd like to
put kind of infinite dimensional
uh i mean instead of putting
instead of saying that these variables
come from some finite dimensional
space you would like to kind of
say that these variables come from some
large family which may be
infinite-dimensional and
if one can get
efficient algorithms for
uh for learning the distribution in that
sense i think that would be important i
i just
i mean you say non-parametric so
you want to get a fire stress type of
you know transportation class type of
estimate
right at the beginning in your first
problem you had uh
you have you were comparing two
distributions and you knew the model
right thank you
so why use total variation distance
there so some somehow from the causal
perspective what i would really care
about is that
the causal effects are different okay so
what's the motivation for that right i
mean
yeah i mean so um
so you can generate the
so if you have a description of the the
causal model you can also have a
description of the interventional
distribution right i mean i mean it's
easy to get the description just like
substituting values for some of the
variables
and you could also ask the same question
for the interventional distribution
but this was a kind of a general problem
where you have a distribution on n
variables
and
um right so it makes sense when when the
distribution is on a high dimensional
space uh but if it's only an estimate
about
about a marginal then of course i mean
that is quite easy
but why worry about the graphs then
focus on distributions
right we are focusing on the
distribution but the graph is a way to
regularize the distribution so we are
saying that the distribution is simple
in the sense that it can be generated by
a
base net by a sparse business
right so the question is about the
distribution right
i guess i'm wondering is that if i'm a
causal modeler
what i care about is the difference in
causal effects
and and since i know that distributions
can look very similar even for very
different underlying graphs
then it seems like the distance metric
that i should be using
to compare the two models for which i
have so much information should not be
just looking at the observational
distribution
right right so this is for the
observational but i mean if there's a
particular interventional distribution
you care about right i mean you can
write a description of that
interventional distribution
and and apply the same same result
hey let's thank garnov again
break now come back here at 10 40 for
leonard stuff